joining us now from the athletic also
does a lot of sideline work for Fox
Sports college football is our friend
here on the week before the draft and
the day after many of the big five power
five conference commissioners chatted
with the vice president in the United
States about potentially having a season
or not Bruce Feldman back here in the
Rich Eisen show how are you Bruce I am
doing well rich it's been interesting
times obviously for all of us no doubt
man I I trust I know we were discussing
off air but I definitely want to bring
it on everybody finding your family
correct yes thankfully you knocking on
knocking on wood right there so what can
you tell us about what the college big
power five commissioners think about the
season right now it seems to be pretty
dire at the moment yes so there was a
call yesterday with Vice President Mike
Pence and really all the conference
commissioners not just the power five
but everybody in in FBS football and I
think one of the things that that they
wanted to make clear because look if you
don't you know work in the space of
college sports you don't probably
realize even if you know it's college
football is different from Kyle college
basketball the NCAA runs the college
basketball tournament the NCAA does not
run the college football playoff and so
one of the things that you know they had
pointed out just to be clear is that
until the universities feel like it's
safe for their students to come back on
campus and participate in activities
they can't have and that's that's just a
reality that that several of the
conference commissioners have you know
pointed out just just to be clear on
that front now who knows how things are
going to be different you know a month
from now two months from now three
months from now but keep in mind that
it's gonna take you know six to eight
weeks maybe four teams if they get an
all-clear to get ready for actual homes
for their own safety reasons beyond
beyond the Cova tissue of just health
and and conditioning
but but also you got to remember we're
talking about a hundred man rosters you
know another 50 people and support
staffs it's like what is the testing
gonna be like what is some of the other
challenges that that are gonna go into
this so who knows of a seasons gonna be
able to start on time I know I talked to
some people were inside college sports
who you know consider the prospects of
the season being delayed possibly even
till 2021 the started the 2021 calendar
but at least would get the college
football season if it had to come to
that to take place within the academic
calendar and what that really means is
college football drives of both
financially for college athletics I mean
if they don't have it the money that
comes from it it'd be devastating
towards universities and and not just
their athletic programs but a lot of
other things that that college football
helps fund yeah we we had your colleague
at Stadium Bret McMurphy on a couple
weeks ago when he was reporting about a
poll that he conducted with a lot of
athletic directors across the country
and how many of them thought that there
was gonna be no season and he mentioned
the same thing you just did let's just
play that out why would anybody like
Trevor Lawrence or anybody that would be
atop an NFL Draft go ahead and play a
college season that is out of season in
a way and would not be would be going on
I'd imagine when the the NFL would be
having a combine if everybody's back
well enough to play football then then
then the NFL would be conducting its
it's offseason if you will unless the
NFL season gets pushed to I it just
strikes me that that would that would
not be workable just to have college
football I mean obviously you can play
it but maybe the stars of the game would
be sitting that one out don't you think
yeah I mean the example used as Trevor
Lawrence Herman Lawrence is a unique
case in that regard now I'm not saying
what you would decide to do if his team
is playing would he sit down fair I got
to get ready for the combine or I can't
risk injuries or who knows
you know I I think we're in such
uncharted waters here the idea of people
saying wait a minute you know I mean
look where you went to college
it's a really cold place it's a really
cold place and in a lots of parts of the
Big Ten country it's much colder in
February than it is in November and but
you know what yes yes I think it came to
that people would would have to try to
find a way to make it work and I think
getting back to the Trevor Lawrence part
I don't think there's that many football
players remember if they don't have a if
they don't have this season I don't know
how many guys you're working off of
where you're basically going off there
2019 film and then a lot of guesswork I
mean there's already so much guesswork
in the process anyway right I think that
would put Vienna for just from that
standpoint I think that look at the NFL
in a really challenging position to try
to evaluate people so I'd be curious
what happens where you'd have like this
sets up but you know some interesting
scenarios because then also you're going
to having a season that let's say
hypothetically this season didn't start
till so late January the seasons
probably not ending so may then so
you're gonna have a season and if you
was that without a season end in May and
then what does that mean for a 2021
season is it piggybacking off that so I
don't think anybody knows I really don't
I mean because there's there's nothing
we just don't know enough about what's
going on but there are a lot of people
who work in college athletics who are
kicking the tires on what-if scenarios
now because right now I think there is
so much up in the air and they know
again the money is so is so monumental
for them I talk to athletic directors at
the you know the biggest schools to talk
about the money involved and it's a it's
a cold hard reality of this so I I don't
know what they would do and then would
there be some some kids who'd say you
know I I can't play if we're gonna play
starting in the winter of this year and
it's going to drag into the spring
because I'm looking at
my NFL future and what that could mean
oh yeah Bruce I mean like for sure just
take a look n and and then obviously I
know a lot of players might feel
pressure in that regard and again I
preface this by saying this is all we're
speculating and and there are far more
important you know things going on in
the world understand but while we're
just you know in this in this arena just
to play it all out absolutely I mean
players need to start thinking about all
that and as much as they'd like to play
one last time with their teammates well
however they want playing from September
to December or January one year and then
going into the NFL is one thing here
you're gonna start seeing the entire
season being placed aside by by
prospects in the same way that Christian
McCaffrey placed inside the Sun Bowl
back in the day and now he just hit it
he's the best paid running back ever so
check that box that he made the right
decision back in that day as opposed to
potentially taking the Jaylon Smith or
you know just name anybody else taking
that route I think you're definitely
gonna have that conversation yeah I
don't doubt it I mean it's i certainly i
don't think that's unrealistic i just
don't know how many players fit into
that today i don't think it's gonna be
widespread where you got every player i
could be totally wrong on this i mean
but i don't think you'd have every guy
who's a potential combine invite which
potential is a lot more than the ones
that end up in india certainly who would
say you know what i can't do this
because i just think that um you know it
would i don't know i don't i just don't
think that many would go it's one thing
to sit out a game it's another thing to
sit out us right bruce Feldman in the
athletic Fox Sports here in the Rich
Eisen show let's talk here and now
what's going on with tool I mean what
what what are you hearing maybe from
your end of things of sending to it to
the next level what you're hearing about
his workouts what you're hearing about I
mean Trent Dilfer says they and Ken
Whisenhunt of remade his base Nick Saban
saying on details on ESPN Plus that he
just
right to do too much that's how he got
hurt he's not going to be an injury case
at the next level what are you hearing
about his stock right now a week before
the draft you know I mean like you I
would talk to Trent and I think I've
talked to some other people in the you
know in the NFL around the elephants
only college people I don't think that
that that too is a brittle guy do you
think that there you know what certain
guys have some some some you know injury
corks where it can happen in the course
of just it's a very physical game and
everyday I don't know how many guys how
many quarterbacks would have taken the
hit he did from Mississippi State and
been able to you know keep playing
through it I just think that you know
sometimes as you spin the wheel and
that's what happens I mean the here's
what I would say about to us in terms of
his arm talent in terms of his
anticipation and how he sees the feel as
well as his kind of demeanor and how
people respond to him because I've
talked to a lot of people inside the
Alabama program over the last years I
would roll if your medical people had
signed off on to me that's the biggest
question but if they have I would
definitely roll the dice on on to us
because the talent level is so it is so
impressive that he has from in terms of
his anticipation how he sees it how he
triggers and how the ball comes out I
mean if I was gonna be wrong I would be
wrong I would be wrong on that front
at least your your your you'd be missing
on a guy with a very very high ceiling
if somehow the injuries come back to
bite them but I don't think you can look
at it if your if your medical people
sign off on him then I think that that's
something that you know teams have got
to decide because to me I would be more
comfortable with him than a couple other
quarterbacks a little later who are way
more inconsistent from what they do on
the field and that would give me a lot
more pause than well he might get hurt
well those guys might get hurt so the
the pause on someone like love is the
fact that he had a drop off last year at
Utah State I just did not see any Utah
State football I admit that
what what happened last year and what do
you think might be playing into that one
week before we're expecting to hear his
name well Matt Wells was his guy that
was the coach at Utah State who found
him
yeah here in like the San Bernardino
area and nobody else was interested in
them he was a skinny guy who threw it
well and well did a great job with him
and then well it's got the Texas Tech
job and that staff left and the new
staff wasn't able to I don't know they
tried to replicate what they did
offensively without maybe knowing the
recipe because they didn't have
holdovers from that same group and I
think you know this is stuff I talked to
from from coaches who were you know
interviewed about the combine I mean he
is he is talented but there is a
consistency issue that would give me
some pause you know he struggled at
times and and I think there's to me
there is that story about like hey you
know quarterbacks it's so critical about
what position you know what situation
they go into I think Jordan love is that
times five I mean I think he is the one
who could be all over the map in terms
of if he doesn't go into like the ideal
situation I think it I think it's gonna
be a big challenge for him now if he
does go into a really good situation and
they nurture him and they give him time
to develop I think he could be a really
really good starting and I thought
quarterback but there's a lot to me
there's more factors of uncertainty with
Jordan love than there is with any other
really talented quarterback in stress
Bruce Feldman the athletic college
football insider of Fox Sports here on
the Rich Eisen show so in terms of
talented guys hoody thinks the most
talented kid in this draft what do you
got for me you know if I'm talking smart
and I'm talking competitiveness as
talent I'm taking Joel Burrell I was
around that LSU team a lot for the last
month of the season and he is a he's as
smart as any quarterback he's come into
the league in a long time from college
football he's athletic enough where he
can make some plays and the presence he
has with his team there's a chip on his
shoulder you know I have
to me he's there's no such thing as a
can't-miss guy I thought that as a
quarterback I thought Andrew Luck was
the closest thing I've seen in the
college football quarterback coming out
but I think he is the safest pick
because of how smart he is how he sees
the field and also there is a Moxie to
him I remember talking you know here on
the staff at LSU talk about when Joe
gets ticked off he you know like he he's
sticking in people's face that edge to
him I think well Perry will serve him
well and when teammates get to know him
I mean he's I'll go with a guy who's
smart and he's accurate and he's really
accurate and he has really good feet and
presence in the pocket I mean the stuff
he would do and you know in the red zone
on third down on fourth downs
it just was uncanny for a college
quarterback and so to me he's by far the
safest pick of the quarter yeah I know
and and and I do know that we're in the
world of nitpicking and finding flags
and all that sort of stuff and I totally
believe that borough really doesn't have
any on that front I mean I watched him
make every throw man if he needed a high
point it for his receiver he would do it
if he needed to lead his receiver he
would do it if he had to drop it in the
bucket he would do it if he had to look
somebody off he would do it the best
part about him is that he never ever
gave up on a play to the point where
he'd put his own health at risk and he
would be always eyes downfield
it was amazing I mean just that the the
remarkable beyond his years ability that
he we were seeing was quite something
but it was just one year you know what
I'm saying like where the hell did this
come from
that's uestion with him yeah I mean look
I think it they didn't quite have the
same system in place or the talent in
place at LSU when he transitioned there
I do know this from talking to you know
there's a project I've been working on
the sauce season related to LSU and
talking to guys who were teammates when
he first got there they talked about
from the day he got there and kicking
everybody's butt in the conditioning
runs in Louisiana which by the way is
scorching hot at that a time of year and
from that point how he
basically one over a team where he was
the guy wasn't there like one like he
was there during spring football he came
in late the only other example I can
think of a guy who kind of took over a
program you know late at that stage was
Russell Wilson when he left North
Carolina State to go to Wisconsin and I
don't think he had the egos and the kind
of stuff that that that Joe Burrell had
to navigate through at LSU at that point
so this is a quick aside on it so I'm at
the combine and Joe Brady that was the
the past game coordinator who's now on
this video to see with the Panthers and
we were talking about this and I ran
into him and Ken Dorsey was around I see
NFL coach now also but he was Miami's
quarterback on that great arguably the
best team of all time in college
football the 2001 you know that every
team and they were joking you know I was
jokingly would Brady about who's the
best team of all time and he was like
wanted it wanted to say something they
can and I was like you know no offense
to Ken but the biggest difference in
that team because I don't think this LSU
team quite had the level of talent and
stars that thought Miami team but what
they did have was as good as Ken Dorsey
was I mean nobody had a season like Joel
girl just did I mean that was the gap
was a team Ken Dorsey really really good
college quarterback yo girl hadn't had
his greatest season as anybody's ever
had playing the position in college
football before I let you go Bruce um
your your current piece and the athletic
talking about you you've been obviously
covering the f it's it's the athletic
part of the athletic I guess the freaky
athletes you you you I gave you the
floor on this and who you think is the
freakiest athlete available in the draft
this year well the P from that story was
Isaac's opa-locka and it was a crazy
story which started out on basically in
a bar with a couple of NFL guys and they
started talking about how who had the
best arm of anybody they'd ever seen and
it was this 330-pound defensive tackle
who just you know retired I guess like
you know seven or eight years ago and
then the stories of the legend of him
him being able to throw at 75 80 85
almost 100 yards and then I remember
talking you know I finally get him on
the phone and he's talking about what
bet that he still trains and he said
well I didn't take lifting seriously
until about 2008 of the great a minute
at the combine you did forty two reps on
the bench and then I was like if you
weren't taking it seriously that but you
were you know four years later what did
you do and he said I asked him what the
most the other two to twenty five was
Richmond City did 74 reps that is insane
that's like a three that would be
because I was somebody running like a
three eight forty in it so there's 225
pounds on the bar including the bar and
he said he he he lifted at seventy four
times seventy four times he said he
would have his Friday workout Friday at
morning workouts with the Niners he
would get up he would start out by
running three miles and then him and so
after I do all this reporting to try to
confirm that he could throw at 80 85 I
get off the phone I'm like oh great now
I got to chase the 74 reps of 225 I mean
nobody has ever seen anybody done
anywhere near that Schwarzenegger and
his book I guess claims he did 225 60
times in a month
mm-hm so I call will to go off ooh who
was a play for the Niners roll-on was
his listing partner and he swears it's
true so I guess nobody putting up 74
reps in this year's draft
although tristen worse is one of our
favorites that we spoke to I mean talk
about freaky athlete he told a story
about I want to freak this this past
year right Terentius right yeah I mean
look this is a really good offensive
line draft especially offensive tackles
and this guy was the Iowa cranks out
powerhouses and this guy was this
champion wrestler a super strong dude
who did stuff like nobody else had seen
before as a as a the University of Iowa
I mean to me he was when we did our
pre-close going into last summer he was
clearly the number one guy but but just
your talk about the explosive power and
the guys 320 pounds
vertical jump at 35 plus inches or you
know he was telling us the story that
the you know in high school that the
girls tennis team was they had their
tennis court on the other side of a
fence where he was practicing is what
was it the discus of the shot the discus
and he would throw it so far that it
would land in the tennis court and and
he had to change his workouts to make
sure that the the girls weren't on the
tennis court doing their practices when
he was throwing the discus I mean that's
because you know he's in a small town he
might have thrown it really from one end
of this town to the other it and so the
question is is where does he go and who
goes first and so you'd name worse that
guy and then there's chase young I've
never seen anybody this year I know
Michigan changed their entire offensive
game plan to erase him essentially and
you know they got erased anyway Penn
State would let him loose just wouldn't
even block him thinking that they'd used
his speed against him and he was too
damn fast anyway that kids something
else man that kid you know just on him
and this isn't even a freakish thing we
did their game as a Friday night game at
Northwestern you know they're gonna
crush Northwestern but to see him and I
obviously did that great deal I mean the
BOCES come out of there in the last few
years but the thing that was different
about him than those guys was the team
fed off his energy from the moment they
got on the field and warm-ups and to the
time when they're up 40 on northwestern
on the Sun I think he's pretty much out
of the game like he was that you could
see how they set off his energy and I'm
fascinated to see what he's gonna do
because if he right when he was getting
he got the two-game suspension I really
thought he had a chance I'm not saying
he was gonna overtake boil because
burrow kept on playing better but he was
the most dominant defensive player we've
seen in college football
you know maybe going back to sue I mean
cuz sue was just wrecked people at
Nebraska that year but what chase Young
did was just remarkable and obviously
they had a lot of talent around them so
some of the things you're talking about
it's pick your poison and that's a lot
of poison you're gonna be you're gonna
be dobbing down so I mean I think he'll
be a I think you'll go to Pro Bowl
for as long as he's in the NFL Bruce
thanks for the call man everybody should
check out Bruce's work on the athletic
and then we'll chat maybe next week when
we when we've got a draft to talk about
yeah looking forward to it I'm glad we
got it right back at you man
thanks for the call that's uh that's
Bruce Feldman here on the Rich Eisen
show check him out I follow him on on
Twitter you should check him out as well
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here